hello everyone the nerd medic here and
you are watching animated biology with
arpan
in this video we will learn about the
ultrasonography popularly known as the
usg so this is a technique which uses
high energy sound waves to visualize
tissues and organs inside the body
now ultrasonography is a non-invasive
method of imaging soft tissue in real
time
now it uses ultrasonic waves that means
sound waves which lie in the frequency
range far beyond our hearing capacity
and is measured using unit known as
megahertz
now how ultra sonography works
now ultrasonography is consisting of
ultrasound machine console like this and
ultrasound probes now these ultrasound
probes contain
piezoelectric crystals
these crystals when supplied with
electricity can generate mechanical
vibration and can produce sound waves
on the other hand when mechanical
vibrations or sound waves come to this
piezoelectric crystals they again
produce electrical patterns
now when this probe is put over a body
surface and supplied with electricity
the piezoelectric crystals generate
sound wave the sound wave gets reflected
back to this probe the piezoelectric
crystal sense this
mechanical vibration and produce
electrical pattern
now ultrasound works due to the
reflection of a beam at the boundary
between two materials of different
densities because in human body
different tissue have different
densities
now
this electrical pattern
that is generated by the piezoelectric
crystals present in the probe
in response to the mechanical vibration
received back
as a reflection from the tissues is
analyzed by the software in a computer
and a image is produced
now this image is known as the
ultrasonograph
now the reflected wave is recorded and
analyzed for its intensity that gives
the amplitude and recovery time which
tells about the depth of different
tissues and tissue layers and gives an
idea about the location of the tissue
now this allows us to assess the size
shape and structure of the organs and
tissues
now a gel is applied during is usg
and this is because small air bubbles
can be still present between the probe
surface and the body surface which can
give rise to distortions in the image
known as artifacts
now there are different sort of probes
used in usg such as the curvilinear
probe
linear probe or phased array probe
different probes have different
applications
now let us understand how we interpret
usg images
now when we put a probe on the body
surface the part of the image near to
the probe appears narrower and the part
away from the probe appears wider
now
solid tissue such as bone will appear
white or hyperequip because the outer
surface reflects more sound wave or
ultrasonic wave whereas the tissue that
are filled with liquid such as amniotic
fluid in the uterus will appear dark or
hypoequic
now ultrasonography imaging does not
work well for gas so organs that are
filled with air like lungs are generally
not examined with ultrasound there is a
popular saying that goes in medical
schools that air is the enemy of
ultrasound and fluid is friend
and
remember ultrasonography does not use
any radiation so you don't have a risk
of getting radiated
ultrasonography
is done in most women during their
pregnancy
this
imaging technique is useful to detect
developmental defects
for example
ultrasonography is used to detect neural
tip defects such as spina bifida during
your pregnancy
or transvaginal ultrasounds can be used
to examine vagina uterus fallopian tubes
ovaries and the urinary bladder and is
very routinely done by gynecologists
other ultrasounds like doppler
ultrasound is used to look for vascular
diseases like varicose veins
and this
uses the principle of doppler effect in
this ultrasound technique
and
by using doppler effect they try to
image the velocity and direction of flow
of blood through the blood vessels
again another type of imaging that uses
ultrasound is known as elastography
which uses
different colors
and represents the consistency of a
particular tissue
as seen in this
image now ultrasonography can be used to
image eye and can detect different
conditions of the eyeball
now this image shows a normal i usg and
i believe you can make out the normal
contour of the eye
so this is more or less the idea about
ultrasonography or usg
if you have enjoyed this video please do
hit the like button share this video
among your friends and peers and do
subscribe to the channel to get high
quality notes and flash card
follow the facebook page and instagram
of animated biology with urban the link
will be in the description box
also we need your support to make high
quality content on this channel so
support us on patreon or also you can
use the super thanks button in the
bottom right corner of the video and can
contribute using paytm paypal or upi
again if you wish to connect with urban
paricha of animated biologies with arpan
the links will be given in the
description box and for medicine related
content you can subscribe to my channel
the nerd medic on youtube also if you
want to get in touch you can connect me
via whatsapp
instagram facebook or email the
ids are given on the screen
until then bye bye see you in the next